let me show you the craziest [__]
sentence I've heard in my entire life
just search chicken asaurus they're join
us as we learn how scientists took
chicken DNA and created the chicken
asaura I watched this whole video
it's really stupid all they did was they
took a chicken and made it a chicken
sauce
it's a chicken
what do you mean it's from the video
it's the thing from my phone it's a
thing from my sketch that I was thinking
about it's a thing for my toy it's a
chicken asaurus they just took a chicken
and made it into a chicken
they just um
yes they just like
what'd they do they genetically
engineered a chickenosaurus that's all
they did they took the DNA and made the
chicken asaurus what is it though
there's one from the video yeah so is
that what it looks like
no
laughs